we've been covering the supposed
bankruptcy of infowars conspiracy
theorist alex jones this is a very
complicated topic which involves alex
jones being the target of multiple
lawsuits
and
presumably going in the direction of him
owing people a bunch of money including
parents of the victims of sandy hook and
interspersed with this i told you a
couple of weeks ago that alex jones has
declared
bankruptcy and we and others immediately
questioned the timing of the bankruptcy
and of course the useful nature of a
bankruptcy if you're trying to avoid
paying anybody one of the great things
to do is to say you don't have any money
well now alex jones is actually bragging
about two million dollar donations that
they've received he says now they have
five million dollars in the bank
and uh this is something that to me
seems like it would be very interesting
to the bankruptcy trustees take a look
guess what you must have made the donor
mad i don't know who they are where they
are they could be in japan could be in
the u.s could be who knows where i
appreciate them whoever they are bought
hundreds of millions of dollars of
bitcoin at a lower price
back in 2016 never spent any of them and
has now given us
a million dollars of bitcoin and you
must have upset them
whoever they are because oh sorry to the
left of the globalist they gave us a
million dollars more on saturday let me
break that for you while you sit there
and say we're covering it all up and
hiding in bank accounts and all this
crap
so
i mean you don't even need a bank
account to hide bitcoin to actually
we no longer have three million dollars
in the company
barely enough to make payroll and
operate my product we now have five
million dollars and we guess what you
must
so i'm sure this is something the
bankruptcy court would be interested in
bankruptcy trustees the trust the
overseeing the sandy hook parents case
the sandy hook families would be very
very interested in hearing about this
you know i sat next to one of alex jones
former attorneys on a flight recently i
talked about this on the bonus show or
maybe it was on a live stream i don't
think i've mentioned it on the podcast
no attorney-client privilege was
breached because it was publicly known
that this lawyer represented alex jones
at one point
it was quite a conversation
and um you know alex jones on the one
hand
has
a whole area of controversy related to
what counts as free speech and that's
controversial enough and when does the
speech become
defamatory and all of these things are
kind of being legislated right now the
other side of this is this very strange
and suspicious bankruptcy
and i don't doubt for a second that the
bankruptcy isn't justifiable in some way
but the timing is just so suspect so
suspect
and now bragging about having five
million dollars now if you went to him
he would go
for us 5 million is borderline
bankruptcy because our payroll is so
high and our costs to produce all these
various supplements is so high i don't
even know whether the supplements are
actually some people when they do
products
they don't buy a bunch of inventory up
front they're just kind of produced and
shipped on demand drop shipping anyway
we don't know the the nature of that
business
uh but he would say this is just barely
enough to fund our operation it's not
like now we're flush with cash we
certainly don't have any money for the
um sandy hook families but this all
stinks to high heaven and it continues
to point in that direction and quite
frankly i don't know what the end game
is i don't know if alex jones genuinely
believes that these uh manipulations
when it comes to the bankruptcy and
having cash and not in bitcoin donations
and all of it um
i don't know
i don't know the other thing
is uh
whether there's con someone wrote to me
and said alex jones seems confused
about whether they got a million dollars
in bitcoin
or whether they got one bitcoin now i i
could he really be confused about that i
don't think so now if he knows the value
listen i have absolutely no idea but it
would be an extra funny thing on top of
all of the scam that's being run here if
he actually got one bitcoin and not a
million dollars in bitcoin one bitcoin
worth about 30 35 grand at this point in
time i don't know what the future of
this is but it all stinks and the
grifting and the scamming continues let
me know your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at d pacman we have a packed
friday show for you today
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well chile sleeps product the
uhler the cube and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and cube sleep systems and ten
percent off the new doc pro this offer
is only for my audience the link is down
below